they're getting ready to flip the switch  on a new traffic signal at ford apache  and patrick we have a live picture there  they haven't exactly switched to the  flip and flipped the switch just yet it  almost looks like that's the yeah that  was the space walk from the  international space station i was going  to say  there we go so those are the uh the  traffic lights they're still flashing  red commissioner justin jones they're  getting ready to flip the switch and  that'll activate again this is on ford  apache down there around rhodes ranch so  we'll keep an eye on that and that's  good news for commuters there who  definitely there's a ton of traffic down  there in the rose ranch area heather